and we shifted
gears and got into some shoulder snakes
and body tracing making basic loops with
the poi
where you're actually waiting for the
poi to be swinging in the direction
you're about to move your hand
and then moving the hand so that it
overtakes the poi
and the poi makes a little loop-de-loop
like this
these are the basic building blocks
of flower patterns like andy spins
or in spins and they're also the basic
building blocks
of all these sort of linear moves when
you're isos and things like that
they're also the basic building blocks
for snakes because what we're doing with
snakes and body tracing
is putting a loop behind or in front of
the shoulder
and snaking it around the shoulder to
come out the other side
so we practiced four basic entries into
snaking positions
the first one was when i look at my hand
it's like i'm spinning in reverse the
poi is coming
down and towards me and i'm essentially
gonna like stall or make a loop
behind my shoulder turn my torso so my
elbow and shoulder come out in front
and then pull the handle which is
leading the poi head
out like so
the next one is from this cross position
coming back
tucking it up under the armpit and this
is actually probably the hardest one
um not only do i have to flick it up
under my armpit but i also have to i
have to flip it up
and back to the back plane so it already
has momentum to get to the back
and this ends up being the poi head
leads and then my body
and the handle follow
and then you can put those
together on this side on the other side
if i'm starting behind my back my hand
is spinning forwards
it's coming up behind me falling down
away from me
um as it comes down and in towards me
i'm gonna tuck it in my shoulder
my uh my elbow and shoulder
turn forwards and my handle
drags the poi out
and the last one is from this my body's
twisted in a cross position
i'm going to sort of tuck the poi down
behind my shoulder
and back so i have to give it that
little flick of momentum
heading back behind me and i turned my
body after it
and sent it out
and so those two combine together nicely
from there we can do different
combinations like these sorts of things
and we also worked on this
uh more wall plane facing one where
we're sending
one under the arm one over the arm they
both go back at the same time
there's a important distinction the
cross points are going back at the same
time it's not like
split time weaves where one follows the
other
they're literally going back behind my
shoulder and out in front at the same
time
but while snaking
so from the front to the back it's a
little tricky because you have to do
that
flick i'm flicking this under my armpit
and behind
flicking this over my shoulder and
behind then
my elbows and hands follow after it and
everything unwinds
from the back i am bringing them in
close
but i'm trying not to get the point
across my spine so they don't actually
hit like they just did and as that
happens
i drag my elbows and hands and handles
out first and that drags the poi heads
out front
when continually snaking these
i find it useful to actually lean my
body
so that my shoulders are at diagonals so
that it's a little easier to shoot right
into those
over and under the shoulder pockets from
here
the isolator around there you really
you can really sort of isolate in front
a bit but i feel like it still
swings out just enough so that you can
really
flick it back in because you have to get
it all the way around your arm and flick
it right back under your armpit or
you'll lose momentum
and then from there we also played with
turning that
from the front you start to go into this
position but you don't fully flip this
one
behind you per se because you can
actually
turn your body into it so it gets in my
armpit by virtue of me
turning through it i still flick the
other one over my shoulder
turn around a 180 and then pop out
there
we can do the turning behind that
version which begins and ends behind the
back
and it's really hard that's what she
said
um okay
we did the four petal any spin weed
which is essentially a three-beat
anti-spin weed
which really in my opinion isn't
actually a weave it's just very similar
one of the key things that you want to
practice once again is creating that
frame or pocket
between an arm and a poi and that's
where you're
shooting your other poi from this this
position
this poi not only auntie spins up
and comes down but i'm directly aiming
to like shoot it
right down behind the other one in that
pocket
then under and across and this does the
same thing
so this is how to do it like one hand at
a time one hand is just
spinning static and the other one can
sort of
anti-spin through
but for the full effect we're both are
anti-spinning at the same time
your arms are moving at the same time
they're hitting cross points at the same
time
unlike a normal 3b weave where my cross
points are
right out pointing at the horizon and
both poi
keep hitting the same cross point more
or less
with the anti-spin weave one is making a
petal that crosses
up top and then later on you're making a
petal that crosses down on the bottom
so it looks a little like this
where you're trading both a top and a
bottom
cross point and that's why i think it's
not exactly a weed because we only have
one crossbar
you take
you throw it on the wall
you